john ashraf is the ceo of neurogym and
one of the
leading mindset and behavior experts in
the world he went from being a teen who
was often getting in trouble with the
law
to writing two best-selling books being
featured in eight movies including the
blockbuster hit the secret and building
five
multi-million dollar companies
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe
top
nation
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more
and you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best john ashraf
and my take on his top 10 rules of
success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one pay attention to your
self-talk
self-talk is so critical
and so i'm consistently paying attention
to how am i speaking to myself
am i speaking to myself in a kind
motivating
empathetic compassionate way or am i
consistently self-deprecating
and putting myself down i used to think
a lot like when i was younger i'm not
good enough i'm not smart enough i'm not
worthy
those thoughts uh and you know lots of
fear fear of being embarrassed fear of
failure
fear of being ashamed and i still have
the thoughts
every once especially when i'm setting
new goals those come up holy mackerel
they come up
so freaking fast are you smart enough to
achieve that are you good enough to
achieve that even when i got into
really diving deep into the brain
science and even my new book
i had i was petrified to release my book
it took me two years to write it
because now i'm entering another whole
domain of neuroscience and
neuropsychology with world-renowned
experts that i've worked with for years
but now here i am putting myself out
there with hey this is
neuroscientifically correct so i had to
make sure that it was
and but there's a lot of fear but i
understand what the emotion of fear is
it's a subconscious trigger that causes
this feeling that i don't like
and it's a ghost signal for me not a
stop signal for me
rule number two have balance if you have
a big enough
reason why you want to achieve something
you'll do whatever it takes yeah but if
your reason
isn't big enough your excuses
will be so it's a kind of balance
it's it's always a balance yeah and
we're always looking to be in harmony
right we want harmony just like an
orchestra yes
and you want harmony between the
different areas of your life so that it
flows
and sometimes there's areas that are
really great
areas that are not and other times it's
a little calmer
and the more you can be in that nice
gentle flow
the more your life works and then i i
find that the happier people are
rule number three visualize the
obstacles
in the past i used to teach and also do
visualize my goals whether it's my body
health relationships money
charity whatever i used to visualize the
outcome and some of the latest research
now shows in addition to visualizing the
outcome visualize the obstacles and in
the past when we talk about this law of
attraction no don't visualize the ops
because you attract them to no no no
your brain's way smarter than that
so if you have whether it's a belief
that's in your way
a story that's holding you back a
circumstance uh references it you know
something that's holding you back
from achieving x so take a look at
whatever it is that you already know is
holding you back i don't believe i'm
worthy i'm don't believe i'm smart
enough don't mean i'm good enough don't
believe me if i'm skilled in the phone
too young too old i'm i'm to this or to
that or not enough of this not enough
that
so address that and say okay here's an
obstacle
i'm going to visualize that obstacle
being real and i'm going to visualize
just moving it aside and me moving
towards
my goal the very act of acknowledging
that releases the neural tension around
if you do that over and over and over
again
what your brain starts to see is yes
there was a struggle
and so it's worthy of me creating this
neural pattern around this
new effort because most of what we're
doing is you know we're being
we're on autopilot we're just eeking
through the day you know on autopilot
and so the brain loves anything that
makes it curious the brain likes
anything
novel the brain likes a challenge so
earlier you're asking me about you know
one of the brain training companies
other than ours
he said does it work i said yeah it's a
workout for your brain
and if you can strengthen the neural
patterns of you seeing yourself
with an obstacle and overcoming it what
do you think that does to your
self-confidence and certainty builds it
up
builds it up so if you'd if you actually
do the work and develop those patterns
in your brain
as you're doing the stuff you need to do
in the physical world you just
strengthen those neural patterns and
that's what becomes your habits rule
number four switch
no matter what has happened to us in the
past
yes whether it's a traumatic event
a failure somebody who's hurt us
a mistake that we've made we
have to understand that the way that our
brain works is it it does
as much as possible to move away
from anything that could potentially
hurt us
so the first thing that your brain does
is keep you alive
yes but the second thing that it does is
it keeps you away from
hurting yourself whether it's real or
imagined your brain will move away
first protection mechanism
first so if you've had an experience
from the
past where you've made a mistake or
you've disappointed yourself you've
disappointed other people
your parents your parents your teachers
your brothers your sisters your
co-workers
your brain is always looking for
associations and similarities
in what you want to do that might lead
to the same disappointment
or the same uh pain that you've had
before
and as soon as it senses any type of
correlation
it lights up the part of the brain that
remembers the past
and brings all of your past into the
present moment so you feel it
and projects the possible negative
consequences into the future
as soon as that happens your motor
cortex
shuts off the part of your brain that
takes action and the motivational
centers of your brain
it just shuts off and what it does it
either
it either fights it it freezes so that
you are paralyzed
or it makes you run away the other way
yeah so that's
one part of the brain that works but if
you understand that when that
happens you have an emotion and it might
be an emotion of fear
fear of disappointment fear of success
fear of failure fear of abandonment fear
of rejection there's 50
or more fears that we have as human
beings that
we're always aware of in the environment
and if you realize that those fears are
possible but they're not certain
what we have to teach ourselves is to be
aware that those are possible
not certain but then to flip the switch
to the left
prefrontal cortex part of the brain
which is really the
brain that comes up with solutions it's
the brain that comes up
with you know directions instructions
strategies and tactics on how to make it
happen
instead of all the things that could go
wrong
so we have different parts of the brain
that are responsible for different
functions
most people don't know that they can
switch from this part of the brain to
that part of the brain they could lower
the amygdala part of the brain that's
responsible for fear and the
emotional response of fear in the brain
that sends you know epinephrine or
cortisol um
neurotransmitters in the brain that we
feel in our body
and then we feel these neurotransmitters
in our body then we
think about what we're feeling and then
we feel
more about what we think about and if
that's what we
only focus on yes then it keeps
perpetuating the exact same cycle
but we have that's why people are
repeating
same mechanism right yeah there's
there's
uh a term in the neuroscience field
in the brain research field called
repetition compulsion
so we have a compulsion
to repeat things over and over and over
again whether they're good or bad
it's irrelevant so we will just keep
repeating stuff
even when we do things that don't give
us the result that we want
we become addicted to that result in
that emotional state
in our brain and in our bodies yeah and
so if we repeat that over and over and
over again
we become addicted to that emotional
state and then we just repeat it becomes
because it becomes automatic hey this
john asref and do you love good books
i love to read because there's so much
wisdom in books
you get to take somebody else's
knowledge skills research
pay 15 20 bucks and you learn so much
now i'm reading this awesome book called
built
to serve find your purpose and become
the leader you were born to be and one
of my
new friends really smart guy really
great guy who serves a lot of people
evan carmichael
wrote it and um i'm going to read a
little bit from
chapter number one and
i love this piece and maybe it's because
i just watched
the series on tv on michael jordan the
last dance which is really great by the
way also but
one of the things he says here is
everybody has
michael jordan talent at something
everybody has a michael jordan talent at
something you just haven't found it yet
or you have and you don't believe
in yourself enough to go all in
to go all in right and you're a genius i
believe you're a genius and so does he
you're amazing you were not meant to
live a photocopy
of someone else's life you were not
created to wake up
and do work that is below your
capabilities you have michael jordan
level talent at
something and you need to uncover
exactly what your purpose is
and how you can serve and use the serve
so lots of pearls and gems and
motivational pieces
pick up built to serve evan carmichael
rising star rule number five understand
the mechanics
fear is an emotion emotions are all
triggered at the subconscious level they
release neurochemicals that causes a
feeling
we are consciously aware of feelings
that are triggered at the subconscious
level the feeling is the
end point of the human experience in the
physical body
and so when you have something in your
brain that
that a neural network says well what if
this book comes out and you fail
what if it's not good enough what is
scientifically not correct what if what
if what if
my brain brain's gonna process that the
same way as your brain and everybody
else because
that's everybody's brain's the same the
mechanism of how the brain works
it's einstein's brain hitler's brain
genghis khan's brain
tom billio's brain john acetate all the
same functionality
so if you understand the mechanics of
what's supposed to happen
then you say okay great when i feel this
then what am i going to do
so i like to use an analogy of a car
you're driving a car
and you're talking to a friend of yours
and a light pops up on the dash
you don't take a hammer and hit a light
it's a signal something's happening
in the in the in the engine in the trunk
in the in the tire
something's happening emotions and
feelings aren't
positive or negative they're empowering
or
disempowering to varying degrees if you
don't understand them
rule number six meditate what does your
morning routine look like now
what what's you know so today was a
little bit different except for one
thing because i drove from san diego to
la to be with you
but i wake up i pee i do my meditation
20 to 30 minutes every morning i don't
care where i am in the world that's what
are these
ones on during that time i i do a
variety of different meditations so
there's
meditations that i can do where i'm just
observing
my thoughts now a lot of people think
well if i'm not supposed to have
thoughts when you meditate
says whom there's hundreds of different
ways
to practice awareness see meditation is
the art of awareness
awareness internally awareness
externally but also the
various millions of layers that exist in
the physical and the non-physical world
so this morning i did a meditation with
some ocean sounds
and so it was um about five o'clock i
woke up this morning sat in my
little sofa you know with my feet
propped up and did a 20-so
minute meditation in the dark with the
ocean just
listening to the ocean just paying
attention going into a trance-like state
where after two or three minutes like i
disappeared like my body
was part of air and space so today was
i was using sound to get into that
trance-like state
other days i'll do a mantra whether it's
you know a lot of people know
transcendental meditation so it's the
om mantra so you just take a deep breath
in
and then as you exhale
[Laughter]
and the question is why would you do
that and the answer is anytime you can
give your brain
a rhythm it will entrain to that rhythm
that's
one anytime you could pay attention to
your breath
inhale and exhale you turn off the
parasympathetic nervous system
um you turn on the parasympathetic
nervous system which is your rest and
relaxation and your calm state of flow
versus your sympathetic nervous system
which is the stress response system of
adrenaline
norepinephrine cortisol etc so when you
get the serotonin oxytocin and dopamine
going
and you're in that state of calmness
you're able to enter deeper
levels of consciousness and awareness so
you're able to
observe a thought you're able to hear
your heartbeat you're able to
sense different things that are giving
are being risen in your body through
thoughts that you're having so you can
actually start to see
when i have this thought here's the
sensation in my body
and you start to get so attuned to
what's happening what stimuli is
happening within you that's producing
these sensations
that cause you to either take action or
not retreat or move forward
you can start to get a feel for how the
mechanics work
so so do that sometimes i'll put on some
of the tibetan
monks and chant with them so i use sound
no sound i use breathing i use open eye
close die five minutes ten minutes 30
minutes
so i practice the art
of being in control of my breath
not breathing just being one with the
entire universe and feeling this
other than normal state of consciousness
that we're used to it's not
sleep and it's not you know conscious
awareness you're in an
altered state of awareness and you can
you can
enter deeper and deeper and deeper
layers
of energy which everything is made up
anyway everything's connected we have
this
obviously our physical body but the
space between you and i right now
there's just vibrating packets of energy
right and so you're able to
access different layers of all of the
intelligence and
information that already exists in the
universe versus the memories that we
have in our brains
and that's magical rule number seven
follow the 5r
principle we developed our company at
praxis
we developed a process called the 5r
process and the first r stands for
recognize your thought patterns
recognize your emotions recognize your
behaviors
and ask yourself are they going to move
me towards what i want
or away from what i want okay so you
don't you don't try to change anything
just ask yourself you recognize just
become more aware
and then instead of reacting
to what you don't like you learn how to
respond
that's the second r so recognize then
respond
hmm can i change this can i change the
meaning of this can i change the emotion
of this can i change
you know anything about this that is
destructive
and the answer is yes the third part
is to reframe anything that doesn't work
for you
so whether it's a person a situation a
circumstance
how can you reframe it look at it from a
different point
of view so that it doesn't have the same
meaning anymore
and one of the things that we know is
the meaning that we give
anything determines how we feel about it
yes the meaning we give it nothing has a
meaning
independent of our own thoughts and
meanings
so can we reframe something look at it a
different way
emotionalize it a different way so that
we can use it
as opposed to it using us
the fourth part is when we're feeling a
negative or destructive emotion
can we through breathing exercises
through reframing release that emotion
because every emotion is a wave
so there are six main emotions that we
have there's sub emotions as well but we
feel
fear anger sadness happiness disgust etc
and those cause us to feel a certain way
so
is there a way for us to release the
unpleasant emotions there's not
good or bad emotions they're pleasant
or unpleasant yeah and that is comes
from directly from one of my dear
friends dr joan rosenberg who's an
emotional mastery expert
wow and and so when you think about is
this
emotion pleasant yes okay good let's do
more of that
is this emotion unpleasant okay well
what's causing it usually it's
what's causing is something from my past
that is telling me that whatever is
happening
maybe i can reproduce it well if it's if
it's a
if it's a unpleasant emotion usually
it's a memory from the past
versus reality and so when you learn
that emotions last 90 seconds to a
minute and 20
seconds two minutes and if you just
observe it
and feel the emotion it's like a wave
feel the emotion without getting into
the reaction
of the emotion observe it
now you're in control of the emotion now
you're learning to surf the wave
instead of being hit by the wave and
then the fifth part is now
to retrain your brain so
recognize respond
reframe release and now i want to
retrain my brain
to have a different thought pattern a
different emotional response and a
different
behavior so that i change the pattern in
my brain so it doesn't happen again
and if you do that one time five times
10 times 20 times
the same thought or the same emotion or
the same circumstance won't have the
same power
to cause you to freeze or run away or
fight
now we're starting to get in control
yeah it's great
[Music]
of our own brains our own emotions and
now we can start to use the spiritual
side of our being the higher side of our
being
to move towards the greatness that i
think is within every human being
rule number eight develop habits at a
non-conscious level setting
goals is an intellectual and imagined
exercise
that your conscious brain right i'm
going to show you one of the little
brains today from the city here on my
house
your conscious brain left prefrontal
cortex specifically
where you get to choose what is it you
would love
to have your life be like what is the
imagination
you know of the ideal life that you'd
like he says everybody could do that he
says but achieving goals
happens as a result of having the right
beliefs perceptions habits
attitudes at the non-conscious level
where all of the habits reside part of
the hippocampus part of your brain
that drives your automatic behavior
day in and day out is
what is going to determine whether you
achieve those goals or not he says
using willpower
to achieve goals is like using gun
powder
it's just a starter using
resilience or using your imagination
those are all
really good conscious abilities that
anybody can use he says
but if you don't develop
the habits at the non-conscious level
which
include your self-image for how you see
your life
you're never gonna achieve those goals
rule number nine believe when i was
um five six seven years old i moved from
israel
to montreal i spoke hebrew but not
english or french
and for two and a half years i felt dumb
i felt like i wasn't smart enough and i
wasn't good enough and i was
made fun of as a kid that led to me
being involved in street gangs from the
age of 12
to 16 in montreal in montreal wow uh
we trafficked drugs from florida we did
break in entries
we we had a little street gang about 12
of us that just gone to a lot of trouble
my path was either jail or the morgue
one of the two and uh there's a lot of
successful people that have that kind of
a story for some strange reason
um and at 19 i met a mentor his name is
alan brown he was a real estate
developer
still in montreal no this was in i moved
from montreal after
years of turbulence i finally broke free
and moved from montreal to toronto which
is about
350 miles in canada canada yeah and
um may 1980 i took uh
my real estate course june 20th 1980
became
licensed as a real estate agent and the
reason i did i met a man the weekend
before
that my brother introduced me to who was
interpersonal development
and he was into you know zig ziglar and
dennis waitley and brian tracy's you
know 35 years ago
and he introduced me to this world of of
you know the mind introducing me the
world of changing my beliefs changing my
habits changing my perceptions
of first who are you and he really
helped me see that
you know the spiritual greatness within
everybody the intelligence that's within
everybody he had me start with
getting in touch with that and um it was
very philosophical
and didn't have the evidence that we
have today
on affirmations visualization meditation
mindfulness subliminal programming uh
habit creation
in all of the different methodologies
that we've all heard about whether it
was the astronauts that went to the moon
initially that trained their brains
or the musicians that have or the
athletes that do
the science now is just so phenomenal on
what is actually happening and so
as i was building my own companies i
built my companies by
training my employees not on the skills
that they needed
but on how spectacular they were as
human beings
and the greatness was within them and if
they trained their brain
to have the belief that it is they may
not have the skill or the know-how but
if you have the belief that i can
i will i must you can build a habit you
can build the habit you can
start to if you think about this i don't
care if you if we asked
any question on health wealth relations
career business spirituality we wanted
to
find the answer to something yeah we
could google it and within
minutes have everything we want to know
tutorials everything tutorials videos
audios how to step by step blueprint
color coordinate whatever you want so
our problem isn't how to
all the how-to exists how to build a
business exists how to be a great lover
exists
you know it all exists how to get in
shape right
so i wanted to focus on you know how do
i help more people take more of the
action they know they should be and want
to
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip
is manage your mindset we have this
phenomenal brain
right it's it's it's genius abilities we
can't
figure out how to replicate it anywhere
with billions of dollars
but we are getting some of the users
manual now so when you feel
fear what should you do i teach the
first two inner sizes that i teach
every one of our students number one is
called take six calm the circuits
so if you have this unpleasant anxious
fearful emotion energy in motion
right and it's unpleasant and the breaks
have gone on
if you just take six deep breaths in
through your nose
out through your mouth like you're
breathing through a straw you will
deactivate the stress response center
which means blood is going to go back to
the left prefrontal cortex the einstein
part of the brain can actually think
through this problem
because what happens when the stress
response center is activated blood goes
away from that into the fear response so
you have epinephrine cortisol
adrenaline to be able to get you out of
the situation it's part of our
instinctual brain part of the reptilian
brain the first part of the brain that
was developed was that
then the mammalian brain the limbic
system then the neocortex the thinking
brain
so when our brain has this signal of oh
my god you might get hurt you might lose
this you might get in trouble you might
be embarrassed ashamed ridiculed
judged etc that part of the brain is
going to get activated so if you take
six deep breaths
first calm down calm the circuits first
then do inner size number two is called
ayah aia
the first day is for awareness what am i
thinking right now what am i feeling
right now what am i sensing right now
what is my behavior right now to you
thoughts feelings sensations awareness
of behavior
what's my intention right now that's the
i well my intention is to move forward i
want to do this
great what's one very small
action step that you can take now the
reason
you want to take one small action step
is
one small action step your brain can
handle
if it's one small step towards it the
threat
response goes away but if you focus on
the
end game right away you're gonna get
that rush
and that instant trigger of the fear
response stress response
so the first thing you want to do is
learn how to manage your mindset
and what you focus on learn how to
manage your emotions because they drive
your behavior
more than anything else because we move
away from pain and we move towards
pleasure but we move away from pain a
thousand times faster
and pain wires in the brain faster for
survival mechanisms
so purely from a neuroscience
perspective just understanding self
once you understand okay this feeling is
normal
okay what should i do take six con the
circuits
ayah and now you can start being
progressive and make progress towards
what you want
now i've got a special bonus clip from
john on how to be committed that i think
you're going to enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know where do you need to better
manage your mindset let me know down in
the comments below and if you made it
this far in a video you're still here
watching i want to celebrate you because
believe nation we don't just watch
videos we
do something about it so that's you and
you commit you promise you're gonna take
action
immediately after watching this video
give me a hashtag believe down in the
comments and tell me where you're from
because i want to celebrate you are you
interested in achieving
that vision for your life are you
interested
in achieving those goals or are you
committed
are you interested or are you committed
and
i didn't know what the difference really
was at the time
and so i asked him mr brown what's the
difference and he said to me says if
you're
interested you'll do what's convenient
if you're interested you'll use the fact
that you didn't like school and you
didn't do well in school
to control your thinking and your
self-esteem he said if you're interested
you come up with stories and excuses
why you can't achieve those goals and
dreams
that you shared with me you come with
stories and excuses
as to why you don't want to do the work
necessary to grow
and to learn what you need to learn
he says however if you are
committed he says you will do whatever
it takes
you will upgrade your knowledge you'll
upgrade your skills you will become who
you need to become and you'll learn from
whoever you need to learn
to be able to achieve those goals and
dreams so
lesson number one is no matter what goal
or vision you have
ask yourself that question okay are you
interested
in achieving that goal and dream or are
you
really really really committed and
willing to do whatever it takes
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer on this channel i
have a dedicated brand new channel just
for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there